i see my patients repeating these skin
care mistakes all the time and i've
spoken to plenty of my dermatologist
colleagues and we agree
this is the top list let's get started
but before we do
a huge thank you to my long-term partner
murad for sponsoring this video
pop in those good old pimples as a
general rule you should not
pop your own pimples if you do attempt
to pop a pimple and end up breaking your
skin barrier you risk permanent acne
scarring if your pimple contains
infected pus
popping it can spread bacteria into
other pores hair follicles
and create even a worse outbreak in fact
popping a pimple can actually delay your
body's natural healing process
this is where spa treatments come in
handy pouring on hydrogen peroxide and
alcohol despite what we've been told as
kids using hydrogen peroxide or rubbing
alcohol to clean
an injury can actually harm the tissue
and delay healing the best way to clean
a minor wound is with cool running water
and mild soap rinse the wound for at
least five minutes to remove dirt debris
and bacteria wounds however that are
large
deep or bleeding non-stop should be
treated by a professional you know one
with like
scrubs like this shaving hard when it
comes to how hard you should be pressing
the razor blade down on your skin always
remember
less is more the harder you push down
the more uneven the skin surface becomes
because the skin begins to dimple and
companies have tried to compensate for
this common tendency
making razors that resist shaving
pressure but you will still get a great
nick free shave if you use that light
touch keeping wet clothes on for
too long i'm talking about the rain the
pool the gym whatever it is
wet and sweaty clothing can trap dust
and dirt that clogs pores and often
leads to breakouts cotton is great at
absorbing water
therefore deflecting body oil but all
this high-tech performance gear that
we're wearing
actually deflects water that's why it's
moisture wicking however
it also absorbs body oils and then the
bacteria feed on those body oils and
release a really gross scent on top of
it you put yourself at higher risk for
jock itch and other fungal infections
which is no fun
for your skin falling for social media
fats tick tock
and social media in general is loaded
with skin care
knowledge like this and this
and this oh good there's a kitty litter
on my face
but it's important to remember that
miracle cures don't exist and some of
the hacks we see online
are complete bs also do not assume what
works for a friend or celeb will work
for you everyone has unique skin care
needs
issues and goals and it's probably
important to add that there's a lot of
surgery and photoshopping at play online
taking long hot showers hot showers
are no bueno for your skin they might be
good for your soul but ideally you
should try and keep your showers on the
shorter side
and if you enjoy hot water you should
keep it even shorter as that hot water
can strip the body of oils and dry out
your skin for my patients with eczema
prone skin hot water actually draws
moisture away from the skin and while it
may feel good initially
frequent exposure can actually
exacerbate that eczema keeping small
cuts and wounds covered
so many of my patients believe the best
way to let a minor wound heal is by
letting it dry out
actually keeping it covered and allowing
it to stay moist has been shown to heal
better with a healthier layer of new
skin aka
less visible scarring but if you do have
an annoying scar murad's invisi scar
resurfacing treatment is a great grab
for pitted scars as it has been
clinically proven to minimize the look
of scar size
depth texture and discoloration
forgetting the skin
is its own organ the skin needs to be
looked after just like
all the other organs in our bodies
consider getting regular skin exams
especially if you have a family history
used tanning beds or had many sunburns
in the past knowing what's normal for
you is incredibly important as well so
if you see a mole change or a new one
appear
that's definitely worth a visit to your
doctor no shade no
sunblock you really need sunscreen every
day
yes even when it's cloudy raining or
snowing ever go skiing and not wear
sunblock
sun exposure causes sun spots skin
damage and even lead to skin cancer
using a simple daily moisturizer
sunscreen combo is best but make sure
it's at least 30 spf and don't forget to
apply to the ears and lips as they're
the most commonly missed areas
skipping the good old neck if your skin
care routine stops at your jawline
you're doing it wrong your neck needs
some love too in fact the neck is one of
the first areas of the body to show
signs of aging because the skin is
thinner than on your face
also staring at her cell phones with our
necks bent all the time
isn't doing us any favors ever changing
routines and too many products
as fun as it can be to try new skincare
products doing so too
frequently can create more questions and
problems most ingredients will take at
least four to six weeks
of consistent use before noticeable
changes also know that if you have a
negative reaction it's gonna be really
hard to pinpoint the cause if you
introduce two to three products
simultaneously
over exfoliating with harsh scrubs while
exfoliation is important in moderation
it's
easy to overdo it with exfoliating
scrubs especially when your skin is
feeling dry overdoing it can cause
tiny tears in the skin leading to the
development of a rash like texture
and uneven tone like patchy red blotches
breakouts are another common reaction
especially small rough bumpy pimples
if you're using a scrub on your face you
should do it max two times per week and
when you're doing it
please be gentle don't scrub your skin
raw picking their skin you may not even
realize that you do it but constantly
picking at the skin can cause irritation
inflamed skin and spread bacteria the
digits or our fingers are the dirtiest
parts of our bodies and harbor
all sorts of bacteria that should stay
on the outside of our skin if this is a
nervous habit
try to break it by keeping your hands
busy with something else or perhaps
asking for others
to help point out when you're doing it
without even knowing it fearing thy
moisturizer
skin is meant to keep bad things out of
your body and moisturizing is imperative
for a healthy skin barrier which is why
you shouldn't skip
out on using moisturizers daily many of
my patients with oily or acne prone skin
think they should use this product
less but the reality is they should just
find the right product for them
in fact for me i have acne prone skin as
you can tell and i've battled it on and
off for quite some time lately though i
found some great success with murad's
acne control line specifically the
clarifying cleanser while i try not to
use salicylic products daily i find that
when i'm going through a problematic
acne phase
using that gel cleanser that contains
green tea extract for irritation
i get great results i challenged hiram
to see if he knew skin click here to
check that out and as always stay happy
and healthy
and again huge thank you to murad for
sponsoring this video
you